ladies and gentlemen uh cinematographer
Director of Photography ho van HOA and
composer Ludwig
[Applause]
Goron
hello hello
everyone I really want to say I want to
start with a sincere sincere thank you
guys for flying in just for this
screening I'm joking that did not just
fly in for the screening uh no but
seriously huge thank you to Universal
for partnering up and uh doing this
tonight in this IMAX theater uh which is
really just the way to watch this film
um so I I have a million questions for
the two of you but I am going to open up
to the audience uh at a certain point
when did you both realize wait a minute
this movie is going to be huge in terms
of with critics and with audiences uh
and just have you know resonate with so
many people and and just loving the
movie I guess it wasn't until it was I
was I took the whole summer off and I
was spent the whole summer in Sweden and
I went to small little village
and I remember the day before the movie
came out I bought my tickets and that
little theater in that little small town
was sold
out and uh that's I think when I
realized that that it was that people
were very interested in this movie you
didn't think that could have been
because of
[Laughter]
you no um because the day before the
screening uh I was out in the town in
that little village and my wife Serena
she saw some some some some kids in all
pink MH and she and she was like oh look
they decided they're going to go to a
Barbie movie and then she saw some other
guys back of them that were had like
dark clothes on them smoking a cigarette
and she was like oh they I going to go
to Oppenheimer she and and she went up
and asked him like are you guys going to
see Oppenheimer and they didn't know
what she was talking about yeah I I I
had an interview at 9:00 in the morning
at the at the Chinese and there was
literally
like people posting outside with fedoras
and smoking cigarettes I was like but
but but but but but but to be
serious yeah this film was it was not
very obvious that it would you know
would get the response that it that it
got I mean it's effectively people
talking and
and people talking about science and uh
and um um you know so when it's started
to get a little traction it was it was a
bit surprising I think uh very pleasant
surprise in many ways and of course we
we you know we we did everything
to to make the story as palatable as we
could and um um you know Chris always
had a very strong faith in that this was
going to work you know and we kind of
always you know follow his lead in this
but it was a very pleasant surprise yeah
a lot of people in this theater know how
the sausage is made they know the behind
the scenes of making movies what were
some of the unique challenges you guys
faced in bringing up this film to life
well for me it's very much about that
and that is you know uh on a script
level already you're working with faces
and dialogue you know and and and and U
you know it's on paper it's it's it's
not a very obvious cinematic experience
so I think uh for me the biggest
challenge was you know from the outset
and from the start
to create something that has the scope
but also has the kind of the Dynamics in
terms of its visuals right because you
know a close-up is is is like you know
it's like playing an open cord on the
guitar normally when you when you when
you order Crescendo in a in a in a in a
in in a piece of music it's like the
biggest court is the closeup you know
and if you put a lot of them next to
each CH in a film you know it it it it
it can
become monotonous and you can uh lose
your Dynamics a little bit so for me
that was very much the challenge to to
keep faces and keep keep close-ups
interesting and keep them Dynamic enough
so that you could sort of sit through
the movie and go through the sort of the
different Peaks and uh and and um um you
know uh low points uh as you would in a
normal film you know yeah I think from
for with the music it
was like I I I started right after I
read the script um and you know the the
music needs to make the audience feel
like you're in his shoes you're you're
seeing the world through his eyes you're
feeling what he's feeling and you're not
sitting there judging him you're with
the character the whole time with
Oppenheimer
and so that I knew I always knew after I
read the script that the the essence and
the most important part is to get the
the emotional core of the music to
really you know to really work with his
with his character and all the different
states of emotions that he goes through
and that was that was for me the most
challenging part because he is such a
incredibly complex character and he has
so many complex feelings and try
to go there you know I I need to try to
go there my myself in TR in terms of
trying to get that out and that was that
was difficult at times and you uh going
there meaning you had to learn quantum
physics
and no we all did yeah we all did no but
what was so great about after I after
after read the script is like Chris
Nolan is also getting me involved very
early so one of the first things I do is
you know he and ho is they're having
test shoots and they and and then they
have screenings when when you show some
of the things that you're trying out and
I remember early on I went to uh see one
of those screenings at at I think it was
the IMAX 7 mm theater and I'm sitting
there in in a theater and I'm seeing
this closeup image of like Killian
Murphy laying in bed and and I was I
never seen anything like that it's just
such an intimate um performance and an
intimate in
capturing a face like that on such on
such a format and that had a tremendous
impact in in I think the way I was
starting to hear the music I am curious
what it was like because the IMAX camera
is so massive what is it like putting
that camera right next to people's face
because it's it it is you know it's
different than a normal camera and I'm
wondering how it affects people well
it's not necessarily massive it's it's
it's loud it's it's it it's like having
a small
like a small little diesel engine um in
the shape of a small mini bar on the
shoulder you know um and it's you know
for actors I can only imagine how
intimidating it it must be but but but
it's um you know you have to kind of
learn to to to switch yourself off I
suppose you know um um it's very very
intimidating and of course uh uh Chris
and I decided that we wanted to be close
we wanted to be more intimate than with
that camera than we had you know than we
had done before which which which which
which makes it even a little worse you
know uh but but I just have to say all
kudos to the to the actors that that
somehow um um understood you know the
the the subtlety that a camera like that
can pick up you know and could sort of
do whatever they do you know in spite of
in spite of the noise and the proximity
of that of that beastly
machine and it's not only it's not only
you know the sound of the camera I just
hear but it's also you know my uh weird
face very close in a few finder it's
it's it's it's just not obvious but but
but you know Chris is very good at
explaining the premises of what we're
doing to to the actors you know
everybody knows what it means to you
know to shoot on a big format like that
not only workwise on set but also the
implications it has when you project it
later and what do you see and so on and
and somehow everybody is very much in on
that game you know from the start from
the outset so I read uh that you know
Chris gave you the hint of a violin or
he said something about he heard a
violin uh and so talk a little bit about
what it's like having a director give
you that sort of guidance is it
something that you enjoy or is it
something that uh messes with you a
little bit it's definitely something I
enjoy um you know uh that was the first
thing that he said um after I read the
script he's like I don't I don't have
that much to give you right now but I I
have an interest in seeing what we can
do with having the violin uh Channel
Oppenheimer and his personality and I
thought it was very interesting I was
like asking why and he was he was
explaining that the violin you know with
with it being a fretless string
instrument you can you can go from you
know a super romantic beautiful sound to
something neurotic and based of the just
on the vibr the violin just within a
split second going between those
feelings so I thought it was very um it
was it was a great start um and I knew
and also my my my wife Serena is a
violinist so we spent endless hours in
the beginning just trying to
[Music]
um come up with different techniques and
and also different ways of of using the
strings the channel um feelings and you
know I think traditionally in the
theater and when we see movies the way
strings are used in horror movies for
example it's like these you know big
clusters or you know everyone knows the
psycho strings or these horror violin
string clusters but what if you take
these clusters
and instead of playing them like very
very intense neurotic tone you make it
with a beautiful vibr instead um and
What feelings is that going to make I'm
curious for the two of you uh what
everyone in here is a fan of Christopher
Nolan what do you think might surprise
fans of Christopher Nolan to learn about
working with Christopher Nolan I think
what what what what what I love with uh
with Chris and and and which is not
always obvious is that you know his
films always appear that they have a
very you know High degree of
precision but I also when I work with
him I I I I feel that I work with a
person that can also and is not afraid
whatsoever to work in a very intuitive
way you know he has a very good sort of
sense of things that are going on on set
he has a very good sense of you know
um um um you know he has he has he has
always a very broad idea about about
what he wants to do but when random
things get fired at him he always knows
very good how to adapt and um um you
know and is somebody that is not afraid
to go with a flow in spite of you know
the Precision of of of the work itself
and I I think that very often uh people
don't see him very much as a as somebody
that can be very intuitive and that very
oftenly kind of
mistakenly you know he's so much about
precision and planning but here's this
kind of very strange hybrid in between
that because um uh then you read the
script afterwards again after the film
is on the screen and you realize
everything is kind of written in it and
and the scripts there there you know
then again this Precision comes back but
but on set and I think the actors feel
very much the same he's he's very open
and very sort of uh reactive and
responsive and int intuitive you know
yeah I and also something I think that's
very incredibly interesting ESP special
is his C
curiosity um to especially when I'm when
I'm like in the middle of writing some
kind of m music and I'm using some some
kind of um uh if it's a if it's a type
of composing technique or any kind of uh
computer technique like he's so keen on
understanding what it is and learning it
and and really get getting to depth of
of The Craft and not and I know and I
know that he's like that on every level
not just music but in every different
craft and you know you can tell in the
movies obviously yeah or he comes back
the next day and then has seriously read
up on it and knows more about it than
and knows more about it than anybody
else you know but it's it like like like
with with with music I mean the same
goes like you know the technology around
it like you know U um Optics uh camera
technology lab Technologies um you know
light you know he he he always tries to
know a lot about everything and and and
and I always have the feeling that that
sort of amounts in you know you trying
to better yourself as well and yeah into
result that are always kind of
interesting do you think absolutely and
and especially I mean also I'm talking
about music but also about talking about
sound you know the the amount of detail
that that he puts into into the sound
mix and into the dub stage and have you
know the knowledge of the the subs and
the speakers and like all that
like it's a lot I have an individual
question for you um how do you know as
an artist when your piece of music is
done is it like an instinctual feeling
or do you tend to go back to something
even when you think it's done to sort of
tweak it a little bit I try to tweak it
a lot of times
um and I mean the only thing that I know
that it's that it's done is because
we're running out of time
um and and also with with Chris we we
sit literally through the last day of
the dub with the music like there was
one queue that was that took forever to
to finish and we finished it the last
before the last day we had to wrap the
entire movie and we just we just wanted
you know we I and also with Chris I mean
we know when it's it's perfect I think
um or at least or
maybe but I I I know I know when the
music is done I know when a q is done
but like I'm always trying
to push it and as much as I can and
perfect it until the the time is over
well but there's a beauty to things that
are not entirely done as well right it's
um um
um you know when you when you for
instance it's it's always nice to sort
of incorporate and not you know engineer
things to death and sort of at some
point just accept this is the this is
this is what it's going to be and this
is what it has to be you know that's one
of the hard things about it's hard but I
think we we we we very often walk away
from you know there's like shooting
stunts for instance on on on um um you
know on set and and sometimes those
stunts they they're not perfect but but
but then you're you're you're sort of
weighing like every time you put
somebody through a stunt it's it's it's
always a little bit dangerous and it
wasn't perfect it wasn't the way you had
it in your head but the way it happened
it was kind of good as well and maybe we
should just stand on it and let this be
exactly the way it is and and move away
and move on and um and I think there's
there's some sort of a craft to that as
well you know absolutely having that
understanding is very difficult one of
the things that people might not realize
or maybe they've heard about it is that
this film has no CGI and you have some
very there's incredible visuals in this
that are being done practically can you
sort of talk about um making a film like
this with no CGI and trying to
photograph what he wants photographed
using IMAX cameras or 65 mm camera you
know what I mean I mean there's a there
there's of course a distinction between
CGI and visual effects I mean there's
there there's there's more than enough
visual effects but but every effect in
the film is is is based um um or derived
from something that is you know shot uh
tangibly you know so so every element
you see is at some point committed to a
camera and and some there are some shots
that are build up from several elements
for instance you know but um we yeah we
always try to um do things as much in
camera as possible and and very often
people think about that that we do that
out of some sort of vanity but the truth
the truth is we try to do it in camera
as much as possible because every time
we do an effect in
camera we um we don't have to scan it
and and and and and which means we can
maintain the full 18K resolution that an
IMX negative can can can have the moment
you start scanning it you already throw
away half of the the the the image
quality that a that an IMX frame can
capture so so the fact that we do things
in camera has a very clear purpose for
us and that is you know we want to
maintain as much as possible quality um
uh in the in the original Nega negative
I'll just say that like and I think the
audience will also agree that when I
when I see things that are um just
visual effects with a lot of green
screen or like lighting behind like it
just looks fake to me you know and I
think the way you guys shoot your movies
one of the reasons it looks so it feels
so real is because the Practical nature
and the the you know the analog nature
of what you're doing yeah I mean it
because it is very often not fake you
know I I I think it's just very hard to
to
conceive a lot of things like from
the you know the luxury of a glass
cubicle and and and and and literally
when you do CGI every single element in
the shot uh including the highlight and
the kick and the weird vibration that
the table is doing you have to invent
that and you have to make that up and
somehow uh the human mind uh cannot
compete with uh what what what what
nature gives us naturally on on a way to
do it so so for me it's always very
obvious that you know you try to do
things for real if you if you want
things to be real and and and whatever
you can't do you work very hard to
invent a way so you can and if then you
fall short then you may be Resort in CGI
and you know it's of course very
dependent on what kind of films you do
but um I think this film L lended itself
very very well to you know trying to do
things practically you know all these
kind of things we were doing there were
sort of science projects in itself and
and and so you know doing that you also
learn a little bit and you also have to
invent a little bit things here and
there and you and you see what works and
what doesn't work and and and slowly you
kind of you know study yourself forward
through that uh complexity instead of
just you know
conceiving of something you want to see
and then you know uh putting a vision on
the screen it's it's it's it's much more
something that is you know slowly
cobbled together and and and comes a
little bit from Curiosity and want to
learn you know I'm going to ask each of
you a question and then I'm going to
open it up to the audience for if the
audience has some questions um so like
Roger deacons shoots with famously One
camera and um uh Ridley likes to shoot
with six eight cameras I'm curious what
is it like on set for you guys how often
are you using one camera how often are
you shooting things with multiple
cameras and I'm curious in terms of the
writing of the music how much do you
need to see the footage before you're
really writing a lot like where how much
can you write to the script how much can
you write to those first test shots and
how much is it like I need to see the
movie I think you're your biggest enemy
on on on any of this is is just time so
the more time you have to do anything
anything and the more time you have to
write music the the better because when
if when anyone normally when you finish
shooting a film you're going into post-
production you'd make an edit and then
you know you have 3 four months before
the movie's done before you have to
finish the movie so that's why it's so
crucial to get started early and because
that's really what I think what's so
unique is that we have a lot of time
when when when Chris is in
pre-production two three months two or
three months before before he starts
shooting the film we meet up once or
once every other week or once a week and
I write music every every week based of
the script based of our meetings and we
sit down together we'll listen to it we
talk about some details we talk about
what characters they could work for what
sounds we
like so when he takes off shooting when
you guys take off shooting he has about
two or 3 hours of music that he listens
to on set and then he's and then
sometimes he calls me from set and has
notes um you know what you know this
turns out this is looking a little
different now what if we do
this and when he starts putting his
first edit together with with Jennifer
lame the editor they're they don't use
any temp music so temp music is
something that is used almost in any
every film when you make a first cut you
put in music from already existing
films uh but what we do here with Chris
is that we we put in music from the two
or three hours of material that I've
already written and so immediately from
the jump when you see the first cut of
the film you have a whole unique sound
World a music world something that's
crafted and put together just for this
for this emotion for this feeling for
this movie and
then my job really starts because I mean
we have a lot of music already in the
movie but but now it's time to really
craft into the scenes and get the
material that that wasn't written and
like you know um and also for for this
movie with with this length and and you
know there's a lot of music that needs
to come into place and um so so for the
last you know four or five months of of
this process after we have a first cut
it's it's pretty much uh a a heavy duty
job to get the music in place um and
then also obviously the last thing that
I do and that we do on this project is
to record it all with the live Orchestra
and especially for this film which most
I mean I would say like 80% of the of
the of the music is played by a live
stream Orchestra and just listen and
seeing how much of the music and it
changes um base of the Live players just
the dynamic and really getting that
human touch and the human element into
the music really changed it a
lot because we can we were really able
to play out the Dynamics and now I feel
like in music and and most art and most
theaters and when we whenever you're
exposed to
music listen to radio it's everything is
always compressed to maximum level you
know just B you know cranking cranking
it up you know you see a wave file and
it's just spikes the whole time and I
think with this film sound overall but
also with the music is something we're
trying to do is just really create
something Dynamic you remember also I
also
um love the fact that
you turn up so often when we watch
dailies because we actually all watch
dailies together so so also during the
shooting you're very often there and and
um you know in a way you know get a
little taste of yeah and so on I see a
lot you watch dailies every day and and
I I try to come in there even though
it's no sound or no you know there's no
sign of dais but just getting some
Visual and seeing like the the
incredible footage that that o and GIS
been getting is
it's very inspiring also I'm sure it's
an education in terms of learning film
making and in case down the road you
ever decided you wanted to direct you
know this is like a the best film class
ever why would you do
that yeah I remember I remember I went
to set one day and I saw they were
shooting that scene in the beginning
when Robbie and Robbie and Oppenheimer
are in that little train and they're you
know is they're having a conversation
and that train that it was Tiny that
little train and then you were standing
you I think you were poking in with the
window with your camera it's huge camera
and then Chris was they built this
little train cabin out of wood and Chris
was jumping on this stage to make it
shake
yeah as well as it was not in a studio
but we happened to shoot at um at a
location here
downtown uh that happened to have a room
uh and schedule-wise we had to to do it
that day so we literally built that
train set that is driving to Zurich in a
room somewhere with Chris jumping on it
then shaking the yeah um yeah real quick
because I do want to to the audience but
I did ask you about whether or not how
often you're doing like the Roger
deacons method of One camera at all
times versus the Ridley Scott method of
shooting with like six eight cameras at
all times I mean it's safe to say that
we are um um with a few EX ceptions of a
you know a dangerous stunt or uh visal
effects We Are One camera shell so so so
we work with one camera and one camera
only um you know um we try to be
meticulous with with with what we shoot
you know and and and as well as uh uh
you know in a very old-fashioned way you
could say but but we we work with an
analog camera that has an optical
viewfinder so so whatever gets into that
camera you look through it through an
optical viewfinder it has a very bad
video assist so Chris is usually resting
next to the camera looking from the
vantage point of the camera into the set
you know uh and and so everything that
happens uh in front of the camera is all
you know it's all built around you know
that sort of funnel that goes into that
one single lens and and um and I think
we we both love working like that that
so we're definitely a One camera show
and by the way to have two IMX cameras
next to each other noising it up
that's well hopefully there will be a
smaller camera
soon I I I I I'm not sure if I agree
because you know U there's something
very magic with a with a fact that you
have a set and you plant something in
the middle and and and all the life and
sort of the chemistry on set sort of
starts evolving around that that that
thing that is standing Central there
it's it's a certain respect and a
certain
um um yeah all that people have around
it and and and they start sort of living
their lives and and building their
things all around that that well
gigantic vacuum cleaner there in the
middle that that that is then you know
supposed to suck everything up so I
think the size you know the size is not
problem and and then the other part of
it is that I I always feel it as my
obligation as a cinematographer to kind
of um Master the the the technology and
the discomfort and the the you know in
order to get the best experience
possible you know so you know I'm I'm
not so much into like ergonomic or more
handy solutions that make it easier for
me to pick up or anything like that I
think it's good that it's a little
there's a little resistance and that
that always kind of works in my
advantage but I just have to ask the
audience how many of you guys have not
have you all seen the size of like the
huge IMAX camera that he's talking
about if you haven't look on this thing
called the Google and just type in IMAX
camera and you'll see the size of what
you are by the way the IMAX camera we we
all talk about it like that's the heavy
camera but the system 65 camera you know
the five bir camera is much heavier and
much uh harder in a way to work with
because besides that it sort of pulls 65
mm strips of film through its mechanics
it also is built in sort of a case that
is thick and heavy in order to not let
any sound out so so um the imix camera
feels like a like you know very
ergonomic and easy thing to work with
compared to the system 65 I have never
heard anyone say that the IMAX camera is
ergonomic and and easy to work with
these are these are I mean literally it
no but it's really not that bad I mean
there
there's but there there's like all these
myths about it and when I started
working for the first time on IMAX
everybody was saying like oh IMAX camera
and you know when when I stepped into it
I thought it was like a Volkswagen
Beetle or something you know that big uh
and and people say handheld is
impossible and and and and then at some
point you go to the rental company and
you see the thing you think it's not
that bad and and you pick it up and it's
not that heavy actually and then you ask
somebody to put it on your shoulder and
and and and and just by doing that you
find out it's the sort of the stories or
the mythology around it is is is is so
much weighing so much more than the
camera itself I give you a lot of credit
there's not a lot of cinematographers
that would rock a handheld IMAX uh C
anyway so I'm I'm sure there must be at
least two questions out here um let's
start right here yeah thank you for your
work it was excellent we love the film
uh I was thinking with the way that
Jennifer and Chris cut the film like it
seemed like there was a lot of cutting
around and you both brought so much crap
to it watching the Final Cut Is there a
a specific scene for either one of you
where you went oh gosh that's just
perfect like you have you have a
favorite sced that reflects your work uh
at the most aspirational before the edit
did you have I'm just so people can hear
it did you and I I want to make sure I
got it right did you have a favorite
scene from the way it all came together
in the edit with Jennifer and
Chris I think it was I remember the
first time I saw it and I was like I was
like oh my God this is it felt exactly
like I I was reading the script in terms
of like
I know it was it was it was I mean you
guys got it like seen foreen just like
the script is and also what was
interesting about that is that even the
script Chris is Chris is writing out you
know it's like upen Hammer hearing
footsteps you know it's in the script
also
um after the bomb goes off Trinity test
there's the the the the silence is in
the script too you know so it was a very
interesting experience like that because
it was is is it's it's so close to to
the feeling I had when I read the script
yeah also the cross cutting and so on
you know because because there's a lot
of cross cutting like in in in in in in
its crescendos you know it cuts away and
it comes back into the action and it
ramps up and builds up and it's stuff
that that Chris always builds in into
script level but that's kind of a nice
thing with uh with with with uh with
Chris with working with him is you know
if you work with several directors you
know you you read a script and then you
you have some sort of an image of it and
then uh the film gets realized and it's
it always meets your expectation or it's
just slightly slightly disappointing
somewhere at at different points but but
but funnily
enough you know he takes always so good
care of everybody's work I feel you know
and and and you always totally recognize
yourself back and the tension and and
then he just knows always how to lift it
just that last little bit that that when
you see it for the first time it's like
it's almost like watching a new film you
know even though it's exactly like it's
in the
script um okay wow uh we'll go right
over
here yes okay I was just wondering is
there any way to incentivize Studios
directors or producers to shoot shoot
more on film because I'm never watching
the two good Godfather movies or
Lawrence of Arabia and going gosh if
only it had been
digital is there a way to incentivize
Studios to shoot more on film yeah I I I
guess the the one of the best incentives
is is to to make a film uh and
um you know make it interesting enough
so that people actually go and see it in
the theaters and and when they go to
theaters uh tell that they liked it and
and and um you know um the proof is
always in the pting so so you know I I
don't think you can force people to
shoot on film and I think Studios you
know obviously shouldn't force uh people
to shoot on film uh I think the only
thing you know as a filmmaker you can do
is shoot on what you love shooting on
and try to do it as good as possible and
try to you know connect with an audience
like that you
know that's kind of all we can do and
you know of course I I I I I think it's
very it would be very sad to see film
disappear because you know from a studio
perspective digital will be more
interesting I think it's very important
to leave the choice to the media and
have have those choices of different
media you know and and leave leave that
to the filmmakers you know and and and
please don't force people to shoot on
things that they don't feel comfortable
with or or or like um that's okay right
here yes uh for the music uh there I
thought it was super unique with the
tempo changes how quick and slow and was
there certain influences you had Ludwick
on like listening to other composers or
course of music that sort of brought
that
about uh the tempo changes that idea
came to me during uh
uh when they were when they were showing
me some tests that that they had done
some some some visuals that were very
inspiring it was in an imix theater and
I saw them they had just shootting that
test when you see the molecule swirling
around and I was sitting there in that
theater and like seeing that image in on
an IMX screen and I was and that was
that was incredible feeling and I was
like how can you get the music to have
that effect um and then I I know I
wanted to mess around with Tempo changes
but I also wanted to make the music feel
like you can't feel the tempo changes um
and that was very uh that took a lot of
time and also I used computers to to
obviously to do the tempo changes but I
knew that I wanted it to perform by live
Orchestra and for the live Orchestra to
do Tempo changes irregularly every four
bars is very difficult but we record
them in a way that I've never done
before where you give them a click in
their headphones before the tempos
happen in the sheet music um and these
musicians are they were some of the best
in the world so they they they're so
used to playing with a click in their
headphones every day um recording music
and so they were able to to do this and
for I was baffled so do does that mean
that they played like the last uh bars
to a different Tempo in their ears yeah
exactly
genius and that's the reason why this uh
the soundtrack is so incredible
uh right there yes this is a question
for boy uh I know that it's difficult to
shoot dialog scenes with IMAX cameras
just because they're so noisy but then I
know there's like a good handful of
scenes in the movie that have dialogue
plus IMAX so my question for you was how
do you choose like which scenes warrant
like whipping out IMAX and using ADR
whiches which ones you're going to go 70
mm or just 70 mm ready I mean funny
enough if we if we could have the choice
we we would we would love to shoot a
whole film IMX you know and and and and
and it's exactly that level of intimacy
that prohibits you from doing that you
know and and very very soft spoke soft
spoken dialogue for instance is
impossible however if you feel that you
really want to see on IMAX they shoot it
on 655 per first and then when actors
have it sort of in their muscle memory
you do a few takes on IMX camera and
then you hope kind of that it that that
the sound will be good enough and
matches is good enough so so that you
can actually you know uh show the whole
scene in IMAX uh let's go to the very
yeah the very back yeah exactly my
question is for Ludwig I was wondering
um you've worked with directors such as
um ran CER and uh obviously chrisop
foran I was wondering kind of like
what's your processing changing your
Vibe or getting into like the vibe and
thought process of the director behind
zone for um I think with with with both
with actually with both Ryan and Chris
and what's so important to to the way
they work is that they are like I
mentioned early with temp score they
don't use temp score that I'm getting
involved very early because they're also
writing the the films themselves so that
allows us to get involved at a script
stage where we can have these ideas and
these experiments and and also working
with directors that that are
very that that are interested in music
and have a a musical ear and and can can
distinguish differences in in
instruments and in styles of music and
and are very interested in talking about
it because the more the more you can
talk about it the more you can um
elaborate on your ideas together and
collaborate together the better the
product's going to be I I'll go right
there white T-shirt hand up yes um when
you're when you're shooting or you're
scoring the film so you have like the
scenes of Oppenheimer and you have the
scenes of straws is there like a
different mindset that you're in for for
each of those scenes does the the
perception of the score when you're
scoring change at all for for me yeah
the score the score changes uh yeah when
we go to uh to straw U the music he has
his own theme and his own
instrumentation so you might notice that
we go into like the the the harp uh and
there's like a little fender roads and a
harp it's and it's kind of plays a
little bit of a mystery in the beginning
in if in the very beginning when he
shows him Ron Princeton it is kind of of
a sweet kind of sound because you don't
want to reveal anything but the more and
the deeper you go into it the more you
you play the the mystery and the feeling
of it and then and so you can notice
when you go into those scenes that it
that it's oftenly oftenly accompanied by
by the harp uh I just saw your hand so
let's right there yeah uh hello um been
a big fan of yours for years and you
worked with a lot of amazing directors
and shooting for them and whatnot I'm
just curious is there anything you've
learned on other films that you wanted
to bring to this and uh is there
anything that you learned on this that
you want to bring to Future
films yeah everything I could I could
say you know it's it's um uh every next
film is a result of your previous film
and and and for me like the prep for
this film you know you have always like
12 weeks prep but but I think that the
best prep you have for a film like this
is the you know was for Chris and myself
definitely the three other films that we
did together I think to you know to sort
of you know be in tune that has very
much to do with you know your chemistry
and you know knowing each other's taste
you know uh and I think we rely on that
so much more than for instance a concept
that we come up with in a glass cubicle
just 12 weeks prior to the shoot you
know
um the references that we that we that
we that we pick during a day of shooting
they they're almost always um you know
back to stuff we've done before
together and I'm sure that that is going
to continue into the next film as well I
hope I just want to say that I've just
noticed at the very end of the Q&A that
I put his collider mic flag up upside
down
and I'm super happy on that note ladies
and gentlemen a round of applause for
thanks
[Applause]
everyone